by the way did you guys know that John
is my new et co-host he's got yet
another job I managed to kill the rest
in business and I'm doing the same for
entertainment hosting wheat you are
family now cuz you're coming back again
yeah I guess you had so much fun the
first time are you ready to hang out
with me thank you very much and that's
actually a lot of the reason why uh Seth
and Becca are here today because I know
in past interviews I've been asked of
like how does it feel to transition into
movies and I always consider myself part
of the W family and this is a tremendous
moment for WWE and I want all of us as a
family to enjoy it so I just I'm glad
that they're here I'm very grateful and
it's cool you consider me family but
this is my family so how proud are you
guys of your brother then seeing this
transition and what he's doing he's done
so much for our business I'm watching
him just kill it in Hollywood it's
amazing but what would what else would
you expect rumor has it that you are
gonna go back for WrestleMania 36 is
this true so I know that they're both
looking at me with bated breath as them
being full-time superstars know that
those spots are in WrestleMania very
coveted and they're also earned it takes
a lot to be a daily WWE Superstar it's a
lot of shows all over the world
constantly I just so happened to be
wrapping up a project in Suicide Squad
and will have maybe a free weekend
around WrestleMania but if it's not a
situation where I can add to the show I
don't want to take away a spot that
somebody else's argue that sounds like a
tentative confirmation I'm just saying I
will be at WrestleMania I do not have an
opponent as of yet so so no challenge
laid out but I'm just saying throw it
down throwing it throw it down you never
know you know what I mean I think though
you know you were talking about how the
transition and they're talking to how
you're blowing up in Hollywood wouldn't
that do so much though for Wrestlemania
for you one of the biggest stars in the
world to go back and like make this
event crazy I certainly appreciate the
words in the perspective but like I said
WWE strength is the fact that it's a
continuing storyline and I have good
enough perspective that I certainly
respect all that the day-to-day
superstars contribute and bring and I
love selfishly to be out there and be
able to do my own thing but it's already
such an extensive show that if I can't
add to it just be taken away from it you
can add to it can t just gonna say
you're being very modest I would say
Jack and John Cena
it makes WrestleMania better anytime
anyplace I think so too so I think it
can be a done deal I'm just saying by
the way is it intentional for you
because what the last time I talked to
you is playing with fire now we have
Doolittle really family-friendly movies
that everybody can see and enjoys that
but intentional in your choices lately
oh no I mean well I'm never specific to
the genre material I just like a good
story where we're storytellers in the
WWE and we tell many different types of
stories I'm a big softy inside so I also
get emotional when I read a
family-friendly story so it's just a
matter of whether it's an adult comedy
and I'm laughing my ass off or whether
it's a warming family story that I'm
like wow that's that's a great story I
want to be part of it it doesn't I don't
rule out any sort of genre the past 9
trailer that's about to drop have you
seen it do you can you tell me anything
I have heard that everyone that is seen
it is absolutely blown away and those
that are on the true inside of the fast
family track say that the global
audience around the world is going to be
blown away I'll be watching it as that
audience watches it so I think an ice
internet meme would be like to catch my
face as it rolls but I have no idea what
to expect I just know that they don't
take any shortcuts on anything ok so I'm
taking all that as a confirmation y'all
here families here families rolling with
you we're gonna see you all on
wrestlemania 36 you guys can go at it'll
be great it'd be great jay-z and beyonce
say nobody wins when the family feud's
but come on
[Music]